alors Soran euh Jean-Paul anoven je
crois que c'est votre première
apparition à la télévision et je vous ai
demandé de venir parler de sioran que
vous aimez beaucoup oui vous appréciz
depuis longtemps oui oui absolument une
société secrète d'ailleurs des gens qui
aimaient un peu qui siant depuis
longtemps ça quelques personnes qui
gravitent un petit peu autour de lui
bien qu'il soit plutôt discret et qu'il
ne rencontre pas tellement qu' veille
pas passer à la télévision absolument il
est d'une autre d'une autre planète il
n'a aucun aucun refus d'ailleurs il ne
méprise pas du tout la télévision euh il
la regarde à l'occasion euh mais c'est
pas son affaire oui c'est absolument pas
son affaire alors son affaire c'est
d'écrire alors voilà deux livres alors
rappelons d'abord que c'est un rouain
oui Suran est né en
1911 dans le petit village des Carpates
son père était prêtre orthodoxe c'est
une chose assez importante pour lui
d'ailleurs et il est arrivé en France
vers
1935 36 et là il a eu une sorte de
véritable il était à diep et il
traduisait malarmée et puis tout d'un
coup euh il s'est rendu compte qu'il
devait écrire en français d'ailleurs il
il il il dit souvent que c'est le seul
type d'expérience religieuse de
conversion religieuse qu'il n'a jamais
eu c'est une espèce de désir de français
il aurait pu aussi bien euh partir vers
l'allemand ou vers l'anglaisou qui sont
des langues qui al il a une maîtrce
d'abord parfaite du français oui alors
ça c'est assez singulier il a choisi
d'écrire en français mais pas dans
n'importe quel français il a choisi
d'atterrir si vous voulez sur le
français du 18e siècle donc un Français
extrêmement tenu euh le la la langue de
de hydro il a il a choisi ça très
précisément parce que il sentait
probablement qu'il avait une sorte de de
nature balcanique un peu tumultueuse
faite de de de convulsion d'excès de
déception et il il fallait quelque chose
qui le qui le tienne et il a rien trouvé
de mieux que le français du 18e siècle
et et franchement je crois qu'il a pas
tort parce que c'est a une pH sur le
français magnifique Dean où il dit que
c'est l'idiome je crois j'espère le
citer exactement l'idiome idéal pour
exprimer délicatement des sentiments
équivoque pe oui et puis il dit aussi
que ça a des effets de freinage par
rapport à sa nature bon alors il a
publié un certain nombre de titre oui
alors il a il a donc le le livre le
premier que dont vous parlez qui est
larm des dessins c'est un livre qu'il a
publié à 25 ans 23 24 ans oui un livre
donc écrit en rouain et Suran est donc
tout jeune on connaît enfin il est ivre
de lecture il lit champfort chopanoer
kirkegarde et déjà il s'intéresse à ce
qui va l'intéresser toute sa vie parce
que il a toujours écrit le même livre
sur n'est-ce pas c'est quand même une
donnée tout à fait essentiel et alors il
s'intéresse au aux choses qui vont le
retenir par la suite il s'intéresse au
au saint
eu la sainteté la Sainté qui lui semble
une une des seules variantes vraiment
acceptable de la condition humaine avec
le désespoir absolu d'ailleurs on verra
tout à l'heure et il s'intéresse aux
insomnies beaucoup il s'intéresse à Dieu
comment à Dieu curieux non plus
exactement il s'intéresse aux religions
qui pourrait permettre aux hommes de
faire l'économie de Dieu euh théologien
négatif enens voilà c'est ça il
s'achemine très lentement en partant de
la Roumanie vers une espèce de de de
bouddhisme assez singulier dans lequel
il séjourne maintenant le néant est déjà
beaucoup làou en des larmes et des seins
il il paraî en Roumanie en 1937 donc au
moment arriv fr l'année sont arrivé en
France alors moi je connais tous ces
renseignements grâce à la la traductrice
et ça ça Stoyan et qui donc mais par
exemple il y a ceci parviendrait un jour
à ne plus citer que Dieu les hommes et
les saints mêmes n'ont pas de nom Dieu
seul enemporte un mais que savons-nous
de lui sinon qu'il est un désespoir qui
commence là où finissent tous les autres
c'est déjà c'est tous ces thèmes déjà
commence ça commence à l'intéresser mais
mais pourtant je je pense que si enfin
pour autant que je puisse parler à sa
place d'ailleurs faudrait dire pourquoi
il est pas là voilà il veut pas non il
veut pas il veut pas euh siuran n'est
pas n'est pas du tout un esprit
religieux c'est pas c'est pas du tout
une question qui le qui le préoccupe la
religion il se décrit lui-même comme une
sorte de fanatique sans
crédau ce qu'il aime dans dans la
religion c'est la proximité qu' qu'elle
offre avec des états limites comme
l'extase c'est pour ça qu' s'intéresse
beaucoup au mystique par exemple ou bien
quand elle provoque de grandes dations
des gens qui vont tout d'un coup très
très très loin de Dieu et qui se jette
dans des convulsions violentes mais ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas un esprit
religieux au contraire il voit toujours
là le le le le début d'une catastrophe
n'est-ce pas et et ça c'est une chose
qu'il essaie de conjurer alors c'est
Gabriel mnev qui a publié un portrait
que j'ai trouvé très intéressant de
siuran dans le Figaro Magazine il y a je
crois un ou de numéros et il dit ceci je
vous demande votre avis là-dessus il
faut souffrir d'une extrême absence de
sensibilité métaphysique pour ne pas
comprendre que le furieux combat contre
Dieu que mène sioran n'a rien mais alors
rien du tout à voir avec l'agnosticisme
d'indifférence qui en Europe occidentale
est suite de beaucoup de nos
contemporains
Dieu je n'y pense jamais disait
récemment une jeune femme siant lui
c'est le contraire il y pense toujours
au fond il n'y a que lui et moi
murmurent-il dans des dans des larmes et
des seins oui oui ça c'est peut-être
c'est le point de vue de mznev d'abord
et c'est le peut-être le point de vue du
jeune siuran je ne pense pas que que
siurant aujourd'hui se se situe dans
cette dans cette perspective alors le
siurant d'aujourd'hui qui vient d'écrire
à veux et à Na oui alors le siand
aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un qui au fond
reprend donc c ces thèmes là qu' a
développé ensuite dans des livres qui
sont dont les titres sont très il
faudrait peut-être les donner un peu ti
merveilleux de l'inconvénient d'être né
la chute dans le temps précis de
décomosition pré qui son premier livre
paru en français ça dit bien ce que ça
veut dire oui c'est-à-dire c'est-à-dire
comme il le dit je crois que l'aphorisme
qui qui va être sa forme principale de
d'écriture l'aphorisme dit-il est euh
l'expression d'un moi désagrégé
qu'est-ce que c'est siance c'est un moi
désagrégé qui prophétise quelque chose
comme comme un éant radical en quoi il a
des prdcesseur tout de même parce qu'il
y a il y a des gens dans la Bible qui
sont restés là fidèles au poste dans la
dans la veille et et le la radicalité
négative job par exemple sur son fumier
ou Gérémi dans ses lamentations
maissieur r fait beaucoup penser à ces
prophètes job sur son fumier c'est un
des une des grandes figures de San ça
l'intéresse beaucoup il surûr son fumier
et non mais ce qu'il faut bien voir avec
Suran c'est que il essaie de dans tous
ses livres d'expliquer une seule et même
chose c'est que la seule façon de de
d'aborder l'existence sans sans y être
malheureux c'est de s'attendre au pire
c'est ça qu'il a voulu dire depuis le
début la seule façon de le pire dans le
pire des mes la seule façon de ne pas
être la seule façon de pas être déçu
c'est de s'installer dans la déception
absolue